for a decade the lakes of kenya's rift
valley have been rising
swallowing up land and villages
destroying communities
deforestation is to blame soil once held
in place by trees
is washed down from the mountains by the
rain silting up the lakes below
stopping them from draining in a report
called making peace with nature
the un environment program says we need
ambitious global coordination
to make the use of land and oceans
sustainable
there are vested interests that are
stopping action
there we have subsidies for agriculture
and for energy
for fossil fuels that are perverse they
encourage the use of fossil fuels they
encourage the use
of bad agricultural practices so there
are many people around the world
are trying to impede governments for
insensible actions together
the report says that none of the global
goals for the protection of life on
earth have been met
deforestation and overfishing continues
a million species of plants and animals
are threatened with extinction
and there is much to be done to reduce
air and water pollution
if we can get the business community to
work with governments around the world
i'm optimistic we can start to move in
the right direction
and i think most governments do realize
that climate change
is added adversely affecting food
security
water security human health poverty
alleviation
without action the world is on track to
warm three degrees above
pre-industrial levels by the year 2100
so missing the paris agreement target of
well below
two degrees and like the people of the
rift valley
the un says it's the world's poorest in
developing countries
that suffer the worst consequences of
climate change
bernard smith al jazeera let's hear now
from al jazeera's
manuel arapalo who's in mexico's capital
pollution levels there are so bad that
smog can be seen
trapped above the city it's hard to
think of the mexican capital and not
imagine the city's massive urban sprawl
the metropolitan area is home to 24
million people
and it's constantly growing
the impact of all this traffic
construction and
industry has wreaked havoc on the
region's natural environment
and all of it amounts to one of the most
significant carbon footprints
in all of latin america one of the most
visible signs of this
is the city's poor air quality there are
times of the year where air pollution is
so
bad people are urged not to go outside
due to heightened health risks
it's estimated that air pollution is
responsible for the deaths of some 33
000 mexicans every year and it's a
problem that doesn't seem to be
improving
according to a recent report by the
united nations environment program
progress on reducing air pollution is
mixed with air quality improving in
high-income countries
but continuing to degrade in low-income
countries
environmental experts add that the
impact from air pollution from mega
cities like the mexican capital
extend far beyond urban areas and have
effects on local
regional and global scales let's get a
few from the u.s now
and how the new administration is
tackling the issue of climate change
here's shahab ratanzi in washington
joe biden pledged to make fighting
climate change central to his
administration within hours of his
inauguration he'd signed an executive
order returning the us
to the paris climate accord he says that
every government department will have to
consider its greenhouse gas emissions
as it makes policy and there is a great
deal to do the pentagon alone creates
more greenhouse gas
than some 140 countries president biden
intends to convene a global climate
summit
in april but environmentalists warn that
if the goal
is to control other world leaders to
take bold action he will have to prove
that he's doing the same
and that might mean taking strong
executive action
not waiting for some bipartisan
congressional deal
on emissions the world can't wait
environmentalists say
especially not for some bipartisan
compromise